Musik
Musik Hey, herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-UFO, euer Podcast mit ... Kommt rein, kommt rein, die Schuhe könnt ihr anlassen, jetzt setzen wir uns erstmal hin. Setzt euch, nehmen wir ihn Platz. Ja, das ist echtes Albenholz, ja, das ist ein echter Elfenbeinstuhl, ja, das ist ein 200 Jahre alter Flügel, setzt euch, kommt rein. Aber nicht auf den Flügel, okay. Ach gut, naja, das geht. Glas abstellen ist okay. Wer das ist, das ist Stefan Tietze, der wohnt seit zwei Monaten hier, der hat es ein bisschen schwierig gehabt, ein paar Schicksalsschläge nacheinander. Er war dadurch reich geerbt, reich geerbt. Richtig, reich geerbt, seine Wohnung leider leider in Brand gesetzt, zum Muttertag, als er seiner Mutter was tolles kochen wollte, alle verbrannt im Flammenentferno, aber viel geerbt. Genau, ausser die Mutter, die ist an Krebs gestorben, dann nachher, nachher, ganz unglücklich, während sie von der Feuerwehr ins Krankenhaus gefahren wurde. Plötzlich erkrankt und gestorben, ganz unübliche Sache, wer hier die ganze Zeit spricht, lacht, schreit, lebt, Florentin will. Ja, ich lebe in den Tag hinein, ich bin wie der Vogel im Wind. Glas auf dem Flügel abstellen, okay, ja oder nein? Ach ja, kommt auf an, welches Glas? Also diese billigen Ikea-Gläser kommen nicht auf meinen Flügel. Ich sag mal, wenn es handgeblasenes Murano-Glas ist, dann sag ich ja, klar, gerne. Finde ich auch, sehe ich ähnlich. Auf dem Flukati, Schuhe an oder nicht? Die Diener tragen Schuhwerk, das gehört bei mir dazu, Gäste dann doch bitte in die Fliesspantoffeln, das muss sein. Die Wendeltreppe, bei einem lustigen, feuchtfröhlichen Abend auch mal runterrutschen das Geländer oder gar nicht? Wie gesagt, eher nicht die Wendeltreppe, die 16 Stöcke in die Höhe geht, da kann es zu Gehkräften kommen, wenn man die runterrutscht. Das stimmt. Das kann ganz unangenehm halsbrecherisch geradezu. Deswegen auch da eher nein und bitte, wenn ihr ins Verlies geht, nehmt die Petroleumlampe mit, die Leitungen da unten sind nicht ideal ohne Licht, wenn es geht, ohne elektrisches. Okay, ja. Super, vielen Dank für diese Relatable Wohn-Tipps von Martin Will. Gerne, gerne. Hast du Angst, dass deine Kinder verwöhnt sind? Ähm, ja. Also, dass sie zu sehr in deinem Schad... Wenn es heißt, ja, ich bin der Sohn, die Tochter von Stefan Tietze, dass sie dann zu sehr eine Extrabehandlung bekommen? Also gemobbt werden? Ich habe selber... Oh, gemobbt werden? Ja, ich habe schon Angst. Ich habe jetzt schon Angst um meine Kinder. Weil, also man selber, alles, was einem selber Gutes getan wurde und so gut man es auch selber hatte, man will, dass seinen Kindern gönnt man das alles nicht, weil die könnten ja zu dem Arschloch werden, zu einem Arschloch werden, um nicht zu dem Arschloch werden, der man selber jetzt ist. Und das will ich dann auch nicht richtig. Ich stelle mir das sehr traumatisch vor für so einen Gangster-Rapper, der so aus dem Ghetto kommt und
hartes Zeug erlebt hat und sich so richtig
durchkämpfen musste und dann super erfolgreich
ist und dann wiederlebt und die
Kinder so snobbig sind und das ist
und dann so denkt so, so bin ich nicht aufgewachsen.
Ihr wart meine Feinde. Und dann
hast du wieder so ein Disconnect zwischen den Generationen.
Das muss ganz unangenehm sein.
Also Wohlstand muss ganz unangenehm sein.
Ganz, ganz unangenehm, weil du willst ja trotzdem deine
Kinder in der Gosse aufwachsen lassen, damit
sie was werden, aber andererseits
Vielen Dank. Das muss ganz unangenehm sein. Also Wohlstand muss ganz unangenehm sein. Ganz, ganz unangenehm, weil du willst ja trotzdem deine Kinder in der Gosse aufwachsen lassen, damit sie was werden, aber andererseits, ja. Ich habe jetzt schon, diese Menschen existieren noch gar nicht und trotzdem habe ich jetzt schon so viele Erwartungen an meine Kinder. Ja. Unfassbar viele Erwartungen. Also sie sollen besser werden als ich, sie sollen aber nicht so werden wie ich. Ja. Sie sollen, sie müssen Wünsche erfüllen, die ich mir nicht erfüllen konnte. Einer soll direkt künstlerisch auf den Weg gebracht werden, das andere Kind soll aber auch diese naturwissenschaftliche Bahn zu Ende bringen. Papa, kann ich noch eine Folge Big Bang Theory schauen? Nein, auf keinen Fall guckst du diese grottigen Dreckskack-Sender. Du schaust Arrested Development, Modern Family oder Rick and Morty. Und sonst gar nichts! Ja. Du musst jetzt, ich will aber nicht mehr Rick and Morty, guck jetzt! Guck die Folge zu Ende! Und nach dem Abspann geht es noch weiter, da kommt noch eine lustige Cutaway-Scene, okay? Ob du mich verstanden hast? Egon, schaust du wieder Impressionisten an? Das ist kein Impressionistenhaushalt, nur Expressionisten. Wiener Klassik, ich bitte dich. Das war doch erst letzte Woche. Eigentlich müsste man, weil Kinder wollen ja rebellieren gegen ihre Eltern, das heißt eigentlich müsste man so richtig... Ja, reverse psychology annehmen. Jetzt Heroin, oder? Komm, lass uns Heroin nehmen, das ist doch total schnufte, oder? Was nehmt die jungen Kids, Heroin oder was? Papa, hör auf und knabbern an ihrer Karotte so und dann so, jetzt Snickers, ne? Also ganz heimlich im Zimmer, so Karotten unter Müll. Ich habe dir gesagt, um zwölf Uhr wird Snickers gegessen. Oh man, Papa, ich will einen Pfirsich. Okay, ein letztes Mal kriegst du noch diesen Pfirsich. Ich habe heute, ich wollte heute kochen und dachte, heute machst du mal einen Kochtag. Eine richtig gesunde Gemüsesuppe, ja? Da sind viele frische Gemüsesorten drin, grün, gelb, rot, das ist eine Freude für die Augen und für den Cholesterinhaushalt. Da ist alles drin, was man braucht, wenig Kalorien, man kann nicht richtig satt essen, toll, Zwiebeln schneiden, anbraten, Knoblauch rein, alles rein, was will ich rein, will ich Süsskartoffeln, will ich normale Kartoffeln, habe ich das alles geschnitten und geschnibbelt und reingetan und durchgekocht und Wasser drauf und Brühe drauf.
Und dann habe ich mich so dermassen in eine Sackgasse gewürzt, dass ich da nicht mehr rauskomme. Nein, du kannst mehr raus. Wie hast du dich in eine Sackgasse gewürzt? Erst dachte ich so, was mag ich an Gemüse und dann dachte ich an Döner, an Mustafas Gemüse-Döner, weil als ich an Gemüse gedacht habe, habe ich an Mustafas Gemüse-Döner gedacht. Meringdam, Berlin, einer der legendärsten Döner der Welt, aber die echten Döner-Kenner gehen da natürlich nicht hin. Also, egal. Auf jeden Fall das Besondere an dem ist, ja, aber ich habe so diese ungesunde Angewohnheit, Kommentare schon wieder zu antizipieren. So, und der macht Döner mit Gemüse rein und dann, was ich am besten finde, Spritzer Zitrone drüber. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich dachte mir, geil, dann tue ich jetzt auch Zitrone in meine Gemüsesuppe rein, um denen noch so ein bisschen so einen Kick zu geben. Und dann habe ich die Zitrone reingetan und da dachte ich fuck, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, das ist so intensiv. Und zusammen mit der Paprika und dem Brühgewürz und dann dachte ich mir, ja okay, jetzt hast du zum Beispiel, wenn man sich in einer Stadt, die man nicht kennt, so ist es bei mir im Autofahren, ist eine Stadt so, Mülheim, kenne ich nicht. Wo ist der Marktplatz, wo ist das Gelato, Pomodoro, Eiskaffee, weiß ich nicht. Aber beim Autofahren ist es so, wenn du einmal links abbiegst, biegst du einfach nochmal dreimal links ab und alles ist gut. Und so dachte ich, dass Kochen auch funktioniert. Genau so beim Kochen machen. Du musst nur wissen, du musst nur den Komplimentär Geschmack wissen. So, dann habe ich nachgedacht. Das Gegenteil von sauer ist nämlich. Ja, und dann dachte ich. Was ist denn? Ja, ich dachte nämlich, das Gegenteil von sauer ist Senf. Weil das ist so halt auch so ein bisschen sauer, aber halt irgendwie in einer anderen Richtung. Und dann habe ich, um das wieder zu retten, habe ich Senf reingetan in meine Gemüsesuppe. Senf ist doch nicht das Gegenteil von sauer. Was ist denn das Gegenteil von sauer? Scharf oder was? Süss? Nee, ich denke gerade... Kannst du nicht Zucker in eine Suppe tun? Klar kann man das. Ja, okay, ich habe offensichtlich keine Ahnung. Nee, ich würde gerade sagen, aber ich habe Senf reingetan, aber wie der Grundlage argumentierst du eigentlich gerade. Ich weiß nur, wenn man so ein Wheel of Flavors baut. Das hat schon bei Düften nicht funktioniert. Das stimmt wohl, aber dann ist doch Senf eher neben Zitrone. Ja. Gegenüber ist eher, äh, was ist denn Barbecue-Soße zum Beispiel drin? Naja, da ist so Melasse. Aber das ist halt auch für mich so ein Wort. Das ist halt so, das lernt man im Vokabeltest, ja, Melasse heißt das und das, aber was es ist, weiß kein Mensch. Melasse ist da gegenüber. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Oder so ein Ei. Du, mein Problem ist, ich schaue zu viel Chefs Table. Ich denke immer, ich müsste jetzt... Ich denke auch viel zu weit. Ich denke in Luftballons aus Zucker, in denen so Gewürz-Vape-vaporisierte Thymian drin ist. Ich denke so weit. Ich denke in so kleinen Gerichten, von denen ich nicht satt werde. Ja, genau. Und ich denke immer sofort, okay, ich muss jetzt die Gemüsesuppe neu definieren, dann dachte ich mir Senf, so etwas würde in Chefs Table vorkommen. Und dann habe ich Senf reingehauen. Du musst das, wo John Farrow, der nicht kochen kann, Chop Chop zu Leuten geht, die ihm Kochen beibringen, das musst du gucken. Geh mal weg von Feindining, du bist viel zu weit. Ich bin nicht am Anfang. Und jetzt ist halt so das Problem, ich habe mich so mich so brutal in eine Sackerze gewürzt, dass ich wirklich eingestehen musste, das wird nichts. Da kommt das nicht mehr raus. Das kommt nicht mehr raus. Da kommen jetzt diese ganzen Gemüsekram schon drin. Alles drin. Alles drin. Jetzt kannst du ja bei einer Suppe sagen, du schöpfst das ganze Wasser ab und dann neues Wasser aufsetzen, neue Brühe.
Hab alles weggehauen.
Ganzen Topf weggehauen. Nein, das kannst du nicht machen.
Hast du dich auf ein Fenster geworfen zumindest?
Ich hab's auf die Fensterbank gestellt, bis irgendein Rüpel es geklaut hat.
Was ist mit das?
Weil es zum Kühen rausstellen wurde.
Das ging natürlich um so einen Disney-Film, wo man so einen Apfelkuchen auf den Fenster
geworfen stellt, dann zieht's so aus.
Und dann kommt dieser Koyote und dann...
Ja genau, und Bambi. Genau, der schwebt dann so über der Luft und hängt dann so an dieser Geruchsspur. Und die Nase wird so ganz weit. Ja, ja, ja. Und die Nase hat so Arme und hangelt sich dann so an der Geruchsspur entlang. Ja, so war es halt bei mir nicht. Und ich habe halt den traurigen, warmen Müllsack gemacht und habe da halt ... Es ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn der Müllsack warm ist. Der Dampf in der Müll ist nie gut. Nie gut. Ich habe alles weggekippt und ich habe halt... Hast du den Topf mit weggeworfen? Alles weggeworfen, Deckel drauf, rein, Löffel steckt noch drin. Ich habe meinen Mülleimer weggeworfen, ich habe mit dem Müllsack, ich habe alles weggeworfen. Cut und du stehst mich beim Bahnhof mit so einer Tasche.
Neu vermietet,
Nachmieter besorgt, ja, alles raus, und jetzt
wollte ich fragen, ob ich heute Nacht bei dir schlafen kann.
Ja, das ist gut, ich habe jetzt Platz.
Ich habe jetzt Platz, ganz geil bei mir schlafen.
Aber das war so frustrierend, weil ich dachte,
aber das ist mein Problem auch, ich habe,
weil immer diese Sachen, ich habe halt
Hunger manchmal auf was, und dann gucke
ich das nach bei YouTube. So, aber dann dann zeigen die einem kein Gericht mit diesem Ding, sondern die zeigen einem, wie man das macht. Beispiel Omelette. Finde ich geil, habe ich mir jetzt von den Jungs von Queer Eye, gibt es ein Video bei Netflix, wie man ein cooles Omelette macht. Mit der Tortilla, ne? Egal. Nein, du bist ganz woanders. Ich bin ganz woanders. Das ist die gleiche Form, weil ansonsten hat es nicht, egal. Da habe ich dann ein Omelette gemacht und dann, aber dann ist die Frage, ja und jetzt, ist das jetzt alles, was ich esse, soll ich mit drei Omelettes machen? Ja, stimmt. Ist das ein Gericht? Nein, ist kein Gericht. Ja, ja. Soll ich dazu Brot machen? Ich mache gerade so mega gutes Omelette, dazu kann ich ja nicht einfach ein Brot essen.
Und dann stehe ich da immer mit so einem, ist das jetzt schon Gericht? Nein.
Ja, das ist ein alter Beilagenproblem. Du denkst dir so, alter, so ein geiles Knoblauchbrot.
Dann machst du das und dann hast du halt, denkst du, esse ich das jetzt so? Und dann denkt man sich aber auch wieder, ja warum nicht?
Die gute Regel ist immer, ein gesundes Verhältnis aus Protein, Kohlenhydraten und Fett zu erzeugen. Jetzt ist ein Omelett viel Fett, viel Eiweiss, also Kohlenhydrate fehlen auf eine Art. Da kann man sich überlegen, wie kriegt man dazu? Einfach Zucker, einen Haufen Zucker am Rand. Einfach so ein kandierter Apfel und da ist Omelette drauf. Ja, oder einfach tatsächlich ein schönes Brot, schön anrösten, mit vielleicht ein bisschen Knoblauch und schön so scharf anrösten. Oh, das erinnert mich an Digimon. Digimon erste Folge und ich fand es geil, weil du hast ja gleich am Anfang so eine Gruppe Kinder, aber die Frage, die sich natürlich ein Drehbuchautor immer stellt, wie kriege ich es hin, den möglichst schnell einen Charakter zu geben, dass der Zuschauer checkt, ah, das ist die Kluge, das ist der Dumme, das ist der Schlaue, das ist der Mutige, wie kriege ich das hin, dass in kürzester Zeit, weil ich wieder die Digimon zeigen, wir haben diese ganzen Flacker-Effekte, Für fünf Werbungen dazwischen. Die ganzen riesigen Kreaturen und wir haben die Kaktusmonster und so, aber jetzt müssen wir diese scheiß Charakterisierung noch. Und was die machen, weil die fallen ja in so ein Dimensionsloch und sind in diese Digimon-Welt und dann finden die Eier. Und dann macht jeder sich ein Spiegelei, aber jedes der Kinder macht sich das Spiegelei anders. Und dadurch kriegt man sofort mit, welche Charaktere die Figuren haben. Die man fängt ganz anders an, als ich in Erinnerung habe. Nee, doch, die sind... Wieso sind die nicht so vorher am Kämpfen mit Monsterchen? Ich erinnere mich so, dass sie durch so ein Loch fallen und dann... Alle Spiegelei, erst mal an, erst mal. Und dann sind die in so einer Spielwelt und dann flackert das bild zehn minuten gegen fängt mit monstern an die wir kämpfen und dann fallen sie in dimensionsloch und da machen sich dann feindeinigen gericht was ich sagen will jedes der kinder hat sich ein spiegelei gemacht und die serie charakterisiert die Figuren dadurch, dass jedes Kind das Spiegelei anders macht.
Ja, der eine zerrührt, die eine macht es ganz sorgfältig. Das ist der Rührige, der andere mag es lieber ein bisschen pragmatisch. Der andere ist zwei, ja, so. Mutig. Dann die eine ist die Verrückte und die dreht es dann um, dass es gelb unten ist. Und die Albe, die mit dem Cowboy-Hut, gut, ist auch schon eine Form von Hüte, und die macht es mit Zucker. Und alle Kinder sagen, das geht ja nicht mit Zucker, aber sie sagt doch, das ist mein Lieblingsei, ist mit Zucker. Und da habe ich gerade dann gedacht, dass das vielleicht was für dich wäre, Spiegelein mit Zucker, hast ja auch deine Konienrate drin. Finde ich ganz gut. Du hast jedenfalls, das ist vielleicht ein guter Tipp an alle da draußen, gesundes Verhältnis. Wie das Verhältnis im Detail ist, das kann ich euch nicht sagen. Weiß niemand. Insoweit bin ich noch nicht im Buch. Ne, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, aber das ist genau das Ding, man weiss halt gefühlt sehr viel Dinge über Dinge, die man nachschlägt. Also es ist ja auch irgendwie so ein, man kann ja sehr gut Dinge nachschlagen und nachgucken mittlerweile in unserer Zeit, bringt aber auch irgendwie die Krux mit sich,
dass die Begabungen so, die Amplituden sind sehr hoch und dadurch fehlt daneben sehr viel.
Also man hat irgendwie so ganz komische Inselbegabungen, aber die Inseln sind zu klein, weißt du?
Genau.
Also es ist eine Inselbegabung, aber bei Inseln kannst du nicht überleben, auf keinen Fall. Man steht mit einem Fuss auf der Insel, mit der anderen im tiefen Meer. Ja, ja, genau, du bist so und du bist eigentlich kurz davor, umzukippen und zu sterben. Ja, ja. Ne, so ist es bei mir auch immer. Ich denke mir so, das wird doch nicht so schwer, seit eine Gemüsesuppe zu machen und am Ende denke ich mir, nee, das ist halt schon gut, man kann halt, muss nicht unbedingt Senf und Zitrone reintun, aber es funktioniert nicht. Und das tut mir jetzt in der Seele weh, weil ich wollte mal was gesundes machen und jetzt wurde ich so bestraft durch meine eigene Dummheit, jetzt werde ich halt weiterhin schön mir einen Döner bestellen. Nee, geh mal schön in Rewe oder sonst irgendwo hin, wo es Fisch gibt, frischen Fisch, dann holst du dir so ein schönes Thunfisch, Filet soll man vielleicht nicht essen, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke auch vielleicht in die Kommentare mit. Aber mach einfach mal. Mach einfach mal. Warum zuck dein Auge so? Ja, weil ich schon wieder die ganzen Stefan Schwiers in den Kommentaren lese, die mir schon wieder irgendwelche Links schicken. Können wir auch gleich nochmal drauf zugucken. Holst du dir schönen Thunfisch und dann holst du dir grünen Spargel. Grünen Spargel, wahnsinnig unterschätzt, den kannst du quasi so in die Pfanne hauen und direkt wegsnacken. Super geil, scharf anbraten, mit Olivenöl machst du da Salz und Pfeffer drauf, wehr da ein bisschen Knoblauch rein. Nur Senf ein bisschen rein? Auf gar keinen Fall, weg wieder im Senf die ganze Zeit. Und dann nimmst du den Thunfisch und brätst ihn einfach nur an, von allen Seiten, auch von den Rändern, dass der außen scharf angebraten ist, so, mach keine Ahnung, machst du so neunzehn Sekunden auf jeder Seite und in der Mitte noch schön roh. Auf gar keinen Fall Senf. Das steht auch in dem Rezept, auf gar keinen Fall Senf. Alles können sie machen, sie können fast alles machen, aber Senf bitte nicht. Und dann isst du das. Das esse ich auf, oder? Steckst du dir in ein Loch. Steck mir schön rein. Ins Gesichtloch. Ich hätte vielleicht ein Kochbuch schreiben sollen, wo man reinschreibt, was man reintun soll und nicht alles auflisten, was man nicht reintun soll. Ja. Einfach was nicht reinkommt. Das stimmt, das ist mir aber auch erst nachher klar geworden. Snickers, Snickers, Erdnussbutter, kommt alles rein. Wenn der Reihenfolge von am schlimmsten, wenn sie es doch reinmachen, bis hin zu am wenigsten schädlich, gerichtschädigend. Es ist schwierig. Ich glaube, so Chef's Table ist an sich eine coole Serie, aber ich glaube, ich bräuchte eher sowas wie Brot, ein Stück Brot mit Butter oder sowas oder irgendwie so ein, keine Ahnung, eine Tiefkühlpaere, einfach so auf meinem Niveau, wo ich wirklich was dazulernen kann. Weil so Chefs Table ist halt immer so, ja, der hat halt seinen eigenen Austerndealer und so, der holt ihm die Auster. Die beste Mischung vielleicht für dich wäre dann das Buch Geständnis eines Küchenchefs von Anthony Boudin. Der hat wirklich ganz tolle Tipps, denen jeder was anfangen kann. Der hat auch ein tolles Kochbuch, wo auch Rührei drinsteht zum Beispiel. Einfach ganz einfaches Rührei und ganz einfache Gerichte, die man toll nachkochen kann und damit auf jeder Dinnerparty überzeugen kann. Ich würde gerne mal auch, ich würde gerne, ich will, dass du so gut kochst, bis du mal so eine Dinnerparty veranstaltest. Ich? Ja, weil wenn du an dem Punkt bist, wo du so gut kochen kannst, dass du irgendwie so ein Outlet brauchst, irgendwie so, ja, jetzt, weil an dem Ende von gut kochen können ist halt zwangsläufig, jetzt koche ich auch für andere, weil du bist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Showoff, ist ja auch klar, bist ja auch ein Bühnenmensch. Natürlich. An irgendeinem Punkt kannst du so gut kochen, dass deine Persönlichkeit sich diesem Skill angleichen wird und du anfangen willst, vielleicht eine Dinnerparty zu schmeißen. Schön die Senf aus, dann.
Einfach schön Senf-Omelette.
Nee, Florian, ich kann nicht zu der nächsten
Dinnerparty kommen. Die erste war,
wie gesagt, die erste war so toll,
aber zur zweiten kann ich nicht kommen.
Wir können alle nicht.
Vor allem, ich schaue ja Chef's Table
auf Französisch und es ist
die schlechtest mögliche Serie.
Es ist lächerlich, es bringt mir nichts, weil die zählen halt die ganze Zeit Zutaten auf. So, er war der Erste, der mit Austern gekocht hat. Niemand davor hat mit Austern gekocht und ich schau zu und weiss nicht, was dieses Wort bedeutet und denke mir, gib mir ein Bild, gib mir einen Ton, gib mir irgendwas. Zeig mir nicht die Austern, sag mir, was er meint. Zeig mir mehr. Hör auf, mir diese Steine zu zeigen, zeig mir, was es ist. Das ist einfach so großartig. Klar, andere Leute würden jetzt Makrelen, Shrimps, Pfirsiche und ich denke mir, das sind Worte, das sind Geräusche, es sagt mir nichts, gar nichts. Einfach nur wütend, einfach nur richtig wütend. Zur Verteidigung von Chefstable sagen, auch das englische Chefstable ist eigentlich französisches Chefstable. Ja, in gewisser Weise. Weil Französisch sind schon sehr viel, ja. Nee, es ist nervig. Es ist wirklich vor allem, ich lebe in einer Parallelwelt, weil ich lese und höre viel zu schwere Dinge auf Französisch. Tarkan hat mir ein Buch über Napoleon empfohlen.
Da dachte ich mir, geil, ich will auch so klug sein wie Tarkan, bestell das, bin aber offensichtlich nicht so klug wie Tarkan, weil das Buch kam an und war auf Französisch. Und ich wollte es eigentlich auf Deutsch, aber hatte ich es auf Französisch, dachte mir, gut, jetzt lernst du Französisch. Monate später, jetzt denke ich mir, ich lese das Buch und entweder Napoleon hatte ein fucking interessantes Leben oder ich verstehe die Sprache nicht gut genug. Weil es ist wirklich so, ich schaue... Wenn du begeistert sein willst von Leuten, von den langweiligsten Menschen, gut, Napoleon steht jetzt bei der Welt, der will dich einfach... Das ist auch schwer zu sagen, weil wir hatten ja das spannendste Leben der Welt. Eben, ich denke so, der war Bürgermeister mit zwölf, Mayor, was, der war, wie geht das denn?
Mayor, Trainte, was heißt Trainte, mit drei war der General, Trant, wow, drei, wie geht das? Dann liest du in der U-Bahn und sagst, wow, was liest er?
Ja, und ich denke mir so, also der hat ein fantastisches Leben gehabt, wow, seine Mutter konnte fliegen
Was ist das? in der U-Bahn und sagst, wow, was liest er? Ja, und ich denke mir so, also der hat ein fantastisches Leben gehabt, wow, seine Mutter konnte fliegen und sag, nee, finnisch, ja, ach so, sein Vater war Astronaut, das ist ja fantastisch, es gab es doch erst viel Spiele, da dachte ich immer, nee, und es ist immer so schwer, er hat gelebt bis wusste ich nicht und dann ständig schneit und ich denke mir was schneitzt denn da ständig in korsika was ist denn da los ach das heißt geboren ach scheiße alles falsch verstanden und dann irgendwann liest steigst immer so ein wort nach und dann denkst du dir fuck ich habe alles falsch verstanden vor Und dann irgendwann stehst du mal so ein Wort nach und dann denkst du dir, fuck, ich habe alles falsch verstanden. Und noch jetzt ein unveränderbar falsches Bild von Napoleon in deinem Kopf. Mit netten Menschen mit Flügeln und drei Beinen. Ich bin halt so dumm, ich schaue mir dann auch so YouTuber auf Französisch an und check halt auch gar nichts. Aber es ist irgendwie auch interessant. Irgendwann muss jemand ein Wort nachschlagen. Es gibt das Wort, ich glaube, truq spricht man das aus, t-r-u-c, truq. Und ich dachte halt, das heißt Truck. So, ich dachte halt so, ja, ich bin in meinem Truck unterwegs und hier, ich zeige dir meinen Truck und alles. Was ist denn Stimme von diesem scheiß Truck? Ich sehe keinen Truck. Die sind irgendwo in ihrer Wohnung, stellt sich raus, das heißt Ding, es ist einfach das Wort für Ding und das nutzt wir in jeder Situation und ich dachte immer, was reden die immer, ich check gar nichts. Trucks scheinen einen grossen Bedeutung im Französischen. Und dann warum jetzt ständig? Also es ist wirklich, einerseits macht es mehr Spaß, weil es einfach ein bisschen weirder ist alles, wenn man es auf Französisch liest und die Hälfte der Wörter sich halt so denkt, was es heißen könnte, und auf der anderen Seite ist es auch frustrierend, weil am Ende, dann spreche ich mit Tarkan so, Alter, dieses Buch war mega geil, dieser Teil, wo der dann irgendwie gegen diese Kobolde gekämpft hat und irgendwie, wo der in dieser Schneelandschaft war. Ich finde es ja auch toll, dass er ein bisschen fiktionalisiert dann hier und da ist, ne? Weil diese Kriege gegen dieses fremde Land. Und diese Traumsequenz, wo die mit dem Pharao war? Nee, das heißt Vater. Ach, das heißt Vater, ja. Das heißt, die waren gar nie in Ägypten. Das ergibt wesentlich mehr Sinn, ja, ja, ja. Ja, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob du das richtig machst, komplett falsch. richtig oder komplett falsch. Also eines von beiden, auf jeden Fall ist es nicht die Mitte. Aber dann hört man so irgendwie, damals hatte ich eine Freundin, die dann plötzlich nach Sevilla ausgewandert ist. Ne, die dann Auslandsjahr gemacht und halt quasi kein Spanisch konnte, als sie hin ist und perfekt Spanisch konnte, als sie zurück ist. Wahnsinn. Und halt nur die ersten Monate kannst du halt, verstehst du halt nichts. Ja. Und dann vergessen Leute immer die Übergangsphase, von der ich gerne wissen würde, wie die funktioniert. Und dann können sie fliessen Spanisch. Ja. Es ist wirklich so, innerhalb von einer Woche ändert sich dann dein ganzer Zustand. Ja. Und du hast ein Sombrero auf dem Kopf und fängst an, mexikanisch zu singen und so, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie das passiert. Und das ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes, als was du machst. Knallharte Konfrontation. Dich nur mit Französisch umgeben. Ja, es ist schwierig so, weil irgendwie macht es dann irgendwann Klack oder Klick oder Klack, Trück. Klacky. Ja, das Problem ist, muss man so einen Grundvorschlag beherrschen aber oder Klack, Trück, Trück, Klacke, oder, oder, ja das Problem ist, ich denke, muss man so ein Grundwort beherrschen für dieses Klack. Ja, das ist immer so schwer zu sagen, weil einerseits, so wenn du es im Alltag hast, dann musst du verstehen, was die Leute sagen. Du musst verstehen, was auf dem Strassenschild steht. Wenn du den Film anguckst, dann denkst du dir, ja der guckt jetzt böse, der wird wahrscheinlich jetzt sagen, hier raus aus meinem Haus, ah, jetzt küssen sie sich, okay. Ah, jetzt sagt er wahrscheinlich, oh, ich muss meine Frau verlassen. Ah, jetzt geht er die Leiter. Na ja, gut, dann war auch falsch. Also du denkst dir immer deinen Teil und denkst dir dann, ah nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber so ist es im echten Leben ja auch, dass du auch Mimik und Gestik, die das ganz unterstützen und so weiter. So eigentlich, hä, was ist dein Punkt dann gewesen? Naja, dass du dir nicht genug Mühe geben musst, das zu verstehen, weil du immer denkst, ich verstehe schon aus dem Kontext. Nee, ich glaube, der Kontext, der hilft, die Wörter zu verstehen und so weiter. Ja, aber du musst ja eben nicht verstehen, was die Wörter sind. Wenn der sagt, und er sagt, ja, der ist jetzt wütend und schreit irgendwas. Aber was genau er schreit, ist ja nicht so wichtig, weil du denkst, der ist halt jetzt sauer. Aber halt aus verschiedenen Gründen. Ich meine, ich bin auch manchmal sauer ohne Grund. Und dann denkt man sich, ja, das ist halt genau so. Du bist häufig sauer ohne Grund. Ich bin der Stocksauer. Ich bin wütend und ich trampel auf dem Boden rum und trete dagegen irgendwo und dann geht es mir wieder besser. Gegen Steinen so auf dem Weg. Ja, trete ich so. Hat das mal jemand gemacht oder das kommt nur aus Filmen oder Comics? So ein Stein weg, wütend Stein wegtreten. Wütend nicht, aber so Steine von mir hertreten mache ich schon manchmal ganz gern. Ja, auf jeden Fall macht man das schon manchmal. Aber dieses Wütende, da... Nee, da hätte ich zu viel Angst, dass ich das dann gegen das Auto... Typisch Joe. Und dann so den Stein weg schnipsen. Das ist eine gute... Das hast du dir spontan ausgedacht? Was? Typisch Joe und dann schießt er den Stein weg? Ja. Das ist eine gute Szene. Ja. Das ist eine echt gute Szene. Danke. Wie geht's dann, was passiert dann? Weiß ich noch nicht jetzt. Typisch Joe und dann schlägt er den Stein weg und dann geht er nach Hause und versucht es besser zu machen als Joe. Alter, das ist ja mega geil. Aus welchem Film ist das? Habe ich mir gerade einfach ausgedacht. Das hast du mir gerade ausgedacht? Ja. Das muss man ausschneiden, nicht, dass das irgendwie Steven Spiel da rumgeklaut. Manchmal denke ich mir Dinge aus. Krass. Tritt den Stein weg, sagt typisch Joe und dann beginnt eine Montage, wie er dann anfängt zu lernen. Was lernt er? Baseball. Baseball? Alleine? Und wie macht er das? Weil Joe ist sein Trainer und Joe hat ihn nämlich rausgewählt. Aus der Mannschaft rausgeschmissen. Dann hat er gesagt, typisch Joe, war in den Stein weggetreten, dann geht er nach Hause und lernt dann
am Schreibtisch Pesos.
Hier haben sie 100 Millionen Pesos,
setzen sie diesen Film um.
Wie viel sind das in Euro?
Das sind 200 Euro und sie müssen in Mexiko drehen,
aber es ist die einzige
Bedingung, die einzige
Bedingung, sonst können sie machen.
Ehrlich gesagt, das ist in etwa gerade der
Film- und Serienmarkt in Deutschland.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, Stefan, das wollen wir, das wollen wir, nice, der
hat gesessen, richtig gesessen gerade.
Ja, ja, ja, ist gut jetzt.
Geil, gib's ihm, gib's ihm, Stefan. Ja, ja, ich bin on fire, ich sag's dir. On fire. Oh, ist das der Feueralarm? Was piept denn hier? Stefan ist on fire. Stefan ist einfach nur lit. Nee, Stefan brennt. Stefan brennt. Nehmen wir ernst, das könnt ihr kurz. Stefan ist tot. Stefan war, ich möchte nicht, dass du irgendwas mit meiner Beerdigung zu tun hast. Gar nicht. Nee. Ist aber schon klar, du musst aufpassen, wenn du sowas sagst, weil wenn du jetzt denkst, wo du stirbst, nehme ich das ernst. Ich meine, das kommt dir ernst. Ich bin raus. Nicht raus. Häppchen? Nee, du sollst keine grosse Rolle spielen. Kann ich Häppchen mitnehmen? Weil du bist unzuverlässig beim Organisieren. Seit wann bin ich denn das denn? Hier und da ein paar Grammatikaussetzer, ja. Aber schlecht beim Organisieren? Nee, also du würdest dich ja so rausfrebeln. Ja, aber dann sagst du lieber, ich will, dass du dich drum kümmerst, weil dann muss ich mich drum kümmern. Aber nett von dir, dass du sagst, okay, ich bin schlecht im Organisieren, also möchte ich nicht, dass du meine Beerdigung organisierst. Nee, genau. Du sollst auch keine Rede halten oder sowas, dann wird das nachher, macht es mich dann irgendwie lächerlich oder sowas. Ja, ja, ja. Du kannst gerne am Ende, wenn es dann so, ach nee, ich bin ja bei Hochzeit auch abgeriftet. Gibt es da Reden bei der Beerdigung hinten raus so?
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Also ich dachte halt, ich mache halt so das Klassische, dass ich jemanden suche, der so ähnlich aussieht wie du, Ethan Hawke oder so, und dann lasse ich den aus dem Bus springen, der sagt dann, ah, ich bin gar nicht tot, das war nur ein Test, um zu sehen, wer bei meiner Beerdigung weint. Und dann sage ich, nein, das stimmt gar nicht, es ist Ethan Hawke.
Und dann reisse ich die Mas, das stimmt gar nicht, es ist Ethan Hawke.
Und dann reiße ich die Maske vom Kopf und alle, what?
Und Stefan ist doch tot, also halt schon.
Ich mag die Filme, wo sie sich die ganze Zeit streiten mit ihrer Frau.
Danke, danke. Und dann Autogramme, Autogramme, paar Häppchen und dann halt so leichter Smalltalk.
Fühlt es wirklich aus wie Ethan Hawke?
Schon, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Nee, oder? Weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht. Aber es gibt
doch so... Wer wird dich spielen?
Naja.
Klassiker. Naja, Seth Rogen halt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich fange zwischen Seth Galifianakis,
Seth Rogen und diesem einen Fetty, der beim Aldi immer hängt und Jonah Hill. Und wie heißt dieser andere Fett, sag nochmal. Kevin James. Ich hingegen Klassiker Chris Pratt oder John Krasinski oder Ethan Hawke. Das ist schon ein bisschen hochgeriffen. Aber es gibt auch so Doppelgängeragenturen, wo man so Doppelgänger von Bill Gates sich mieten kann oder so. Ich würde da gerne mal anrufen und fragen, ob sie jemanden für Stefan Tietze haben. Bestimmt. Und wenn dann wirklich jemand ein Name kommt, einfach so Albert Weisler, den einfach mal einladen. den einfach mal hierher einladen mit der Folge auf. Rein auditiven Medium, dann ganz starker ungarischer Akzent, klingt überhaupt nicht wie du, aber sieht einfach genauso aus wie ich. Das war bei, stimmt, das war bei Nathan4U, wo sie den Bill Gates-Imitator hatten als Date-Unterhaltung, glaube ich.
Finde ich grossartig.
Ich meine, um diesen Hollywood-Store zu promoten, weiß ich aber nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, der kam mehrfach.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
In dem haben sie doch eine Frau für ihn gesucht.
Das war auch der 90-Minüter sogar, der hat sich generell zu empfehlen, Nathan for You.
Ist jetzt auch kein Geheimtipp, um ehrlich zu sein, aber kann man mal gucken.
Absolut fantastisch.
Werbung. Hey Leute, mal ganz kurz ein kleiner, ernsterer Hinweis. Es gibt wahrscheinlich einige von euch, die mit der aktuellen Situation rund um Corona ein bisschen berufliche Schwierigkeiten haben, wo es nicht ganz so einfach läuft. Und für die haben wir einen kleinen Hinweis. Denn es ist wichtig, auch in diesen Zeiten speziell online aktiv zu sein, online zu sagen, man existiert und generell die Marke in digitalen Zeiten aufzubauen. Und zusammen mit OMR hat Audi jetzt unter dem Hashtag Audi Together die Videoreihe Go Digital gestartet, in welcher euch Philipp Westermeyer erklärt, wie ihr am besten euer Business online bringt. Wie ihr am besten euer Business online bringt. Also wenn ihr Freelancer seid oder kreativ arbeitet oder irgend in der Gastronomie arbeitet und einfach von der aktuellen Situation betroffen seid, dann habt ihr da die Möglichkeit, euer Unternehmen oder euren Job oder was auch immer ihr tut, eben online darzustellen. Genau, Audit Together sind 15 Videos, das ist ein kostenloser Crashkurs, den ihr euch angucken könnt. Falls euch das interessiert oder jemanden kennt, den das interessieren könnte, dann schaut doch mal auf YouTube bei dem YouTube-Kanal von OMR vorbei oder sucht nach Hashtag Audi Together. Werbung. Aus unseren Serienideen ist leider nichts geworden, Tele5 hat abgenickt. Nee, das heißt nicht hat uns abgeschüttelt, hat uns abgehängt, hat uns zurückgelassen, könnte man sagen. Kann man so sagen. Abgeschüttelt ist eigentlich ein guter Name, aber leider nichts geworden. Aber da werden die sich noch wundern, glaube ich, dass die Worst Bird einfach so verstoßen, denn wir haben eine Menge gute Ideen in petto. Naja, haben wir das? Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ein bisschen sauer auf euch da draußen. Wir haben Streit, kann man so sagen, so ein bisschen jetzt. Weil ich habe meine These aufgestellt, dass die Menschheit nie was draussen hinbekommen hat. Draussen kriegst du Sonnenbrand, draußen hast du Allergie, draußen hast du Nase zu, draußen ist es zu hell, draußen blendet's, man kriegt draußen nichts hin. Noch nie wurde draußen irgendwas Bahntächtiges getan. Noch nie wurde draußen irgendwas geleistet. Wenn ich noch einmal von euch geschickt bekomme, dass Newton ein Apfel auf den Kopf gefallen ist und er deswegen die Gravitation erfunden hat, das Gravitationsgesetz niedergeschrieben hat, dann lösche ich meinen Account. Lächerlich. Weil das ist wirklich lächerlich. Das ist nie so passiert. Und wenn ihr mit eurer so unfassbar arroganten Selbstbewusstseinshaltung mir dann da diesen fucking GIF schicken müsst immer. Das eine GIF, das es von Newton gibt, wo er so in die Kamera zwinkert. Von Newton und dem Apfel, was gefilmt wurde, weil halt die Zeitreisenden, kennt man ja, genau zu dem Moment, wo alle zurückkommen sind. Das ist halt nie so passiert, Leute, dass es nie, also das passiert ist. Das ist ein Urban Myth oder Country Myth. Und erst mal sorry, Newton. Jüdekraft hat eine Gegenkraft. Ja, ach was. Da wären wir jetzt wirklich nicht draufgekommen. Ja. Boah, Aktion, Reaktion? No shit, Newton. No bullshit. Toll gemacht, Newton. Der wäre ein Vollidiot heutzutage. Der würde das Abi nicht schaffen. Nee, der würde nicht mal, der würde nicht übers Rec übers Rec nicht kommen. Newton, der würde nicht mal übers Rec kommen. 100 Meter Sprint, gar nichts. Nee, 10 Meter tauchen, auf gar keinen Fall. Nichts. Mit dem Bart. Ja, dem ist ein Snickers auf den Kopf gefallen. Der war bestimmt ein bisschen proper. Also, ehrlich gesagt, Newton, der würde heute nichts, wenn er diese Thesen heute aufstellen würde, dann würde er irgendwie so, der war so Money, wie heißt der mal? Money Boy? Money Boy, was Money Boy für die Rap-Szene ist, wäre er so für die Wissenschaft bei dem man sich so lustig macht wie so eine satirische Figur ja genau, wahrscheinlich, deswegen war er berühmt der wurde halt ironisch abgefeiert und dann halt so, oh, Newton's Law so wie halt halt heute irgendwie so Jack, Nicolas Cage irgendwie. So ironisch abgefeiert und wir nehmen das alles ernst. Ja, so ein Umgesicht. Das waren keine Zeichnungen, das waren Memes. Genau. Ja. Ich hätte nicht in Newton. Dinge fallen runter, fällt mir auf den Kopf. Gegenkraft, Antikraft, so jeder Kraft gibt es eine Gegenkraft, ist halt auch so einfach wie, weiß ich nicht, ich drück dich, du drückst mich.
Ja, wie du mir, so ich dir, da, da, da, ich mag dich, du magst mich.
Tink, Trick und Track, halt sowas, es ist halt offensichtlich A, B und C, es geht halt weiter. Ich meine, A Quadrat plus B Quadrat ist, ja was ist ... Ja, was soll's sonst sein? F-Quadrat oder ...
19, B.
Nein, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, lächerlich.
Lächerlich.
Die Masse, die in Bewegung gesetzt wird, hört nicht auf, sich zu bewegen, ist eine Gegendacht.
Ja, no shit, Alter!
Wirklich?
Ich dachte, die bleibt magisch stehen.
Die Billardkugel hört irgendwann auf zu rollen.
Ja.
Vollidiot, Alter.
Die ist einfach aufzurollen.
Planeten drehen sich umeinander. Nein, wirklich. Die sollen sich starr rumstehen. Die Sonne geht von unten nach oben, nicht von links nach rechts. What? Im Himmel, ey. Nur, wir sind umgeben von Deppen. Und das geht mir auch auf die Nerven. Die werden abgefeiert, diese ganzen Leute. Und es macht keinen Sinn. Isaac Newton. Isaac. Isaac. Ja, Isaac Newton. Isaac Newton. Was für ein Trottel. Was für ein Trottel. Wirklich. Riesendepp. Zeitreisen, da haben wir auch Nachrichten bekommen, dass es anscheinend Bibi Blocksberg im Mittelalter schon gibt. Wir wollten ja ein Fake-Hörspiel machen, wo Bibi Blocksberg
als Hexe verbrannt wird.
Sie überlebt's und
anscheinend Logiklücke, zaubert
sie im Mittelalter Telefone herbei und telefoniert
damit. Und Hörer haben sich gewundert,
wie das gehen kann,
mit welcher Elektrizität
und mit welchem Kabelnetzwerk das
gehen soll. Also massige
Blockhalls. Was darfst du wirklich passieren, wenn du in die Zeit zurückreist? Ja, es ist schwer vorzustellen. Es gibt ja auch so das mit diesem Ureinwohner-Stamm, den Verkehr von New York gezeigt wurde. Und dann wurde gefragt, so was seht ihr? Und dann haben die gesagt, Hühner. Also die konnten dieses Autogewusel gar nicht wahrnehmen, sondern haben da Hühner gesehen, obwohl es Autos waren, weil wir noch nie Autos gesehen haben.
Ob das jetzt wahr ist, ein Übersetzungsfehler, ob da jemand schlampig notiert hat, ob das hier etwas ausgedacht hat, weil er gar nicht da reingefahren ist in den Amazonas mit seinem Boot. Die kommen ja nach Hause an. Jetzt haben die New York gesagt. Wir haben es denen gezeigt und die haben gesagt, New York. Das ist doch die langweiligste Drecks-Expedition der Welt, die wir hier haben. Ich habe das Ding gezeigt und die haben gesagt, these vagabond shoes are longing to stray, New York, New York, New York, New York, the big apple, the city that never sleeps, if you make it there, you can make it anywhere, New York, Broadway, New York, Broadway, Book of Mormons, Book of Mormons, ja, ja, wenn wir das denen sagen, den Leuten da draußen, dann ist das die langweilige Expedition der Welt. Schwierig. Lass denen sagen, die haben Hühner gesehen. Ja. Gibt's Hühner in Südamerika? Sensation, sie sehen Hühner, obwohl es da gar keine Hühner gibt. Ja, aber sowas ist doch Quatsch. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau, ich weiß es auch nicht genau, aber es ist schwer zu sagen, wie man was sehen würde, was man nicht kennt. Ist ja genau so, jetzt würden die UFO-Bilder geleakt vom Pentagon, aber kann halt auch... Wie seien die UFOs aus? Naja, halt so ein bisschen, halt so wie so ein Ballon halt, wo unten so ein Korb dran hängt, so. Und es stand halt ganz groß, ganz groß. Kein UFO, kein UFO Luftballon. Aber oder machen sich Aliens gerade lustig, weil wir keine UFOs sehen, sondern weil wir Wolken sehen. Aber eigentlich sind Wolken UFOs. Das kann auch sein. Wir sind wie das Uraren, Urarenvolk. Ja, das kann auch sein. Ich weiß es nicht. Ach, ich war, es ist schon, ich glaube eh, dass wenn die Regierung tatsächlich Fotos von Ufos hätten, die würden ja sagen, lass das erstmal unter Verschluss.
Warum immer das eigentlich? Warum glauben wir mal alles ein Geheimnis daraus gemacht wird? Nee, nee, nee, nicht so laut. Wir veröffentlicht das, wenn irgendwas ist ein Skandal oder so, oder das neue Watergate oder so.
Ach so.
Weil die Praktikantin, ich sag mal so, ganz hässlich ist die auf mich. Das stimmt, das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen, Herr Präsident. Jetzt denkt man noch, wenn das rauskommt und alle sagen, hey, was hast du gemacht, sagen wir UFOs, es gibt UFOs. Leute, was ist denn da hinten am Himmel? Ja, genau, und dann hauen wir die Fotos raus und dann kommt das alles raus. Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, gab es nicht oh gut, das ist ein Podcast. Gutes Satz in unserem Podcast, jetzt mal im Ernst. Jetzt mal Spaß beiseite. Jetzt mal, gibt es echt Ufos oder was? Jetzt in Folge 250. Jetzt mal Unschuldig. Unschuldig, gibt es Zufuhr? Dann wird es wirklich ein Verschwörungstheoretischer Podcast. Was immer Leute glauben, die uns anklicken. Ne, aber dann gäbe es, also jetzt, spätestens nach Trump, hätte es dann ja schon geleakt werden müssen. Ja. Es gab genug Skandale, wo die nicht wussten, wie es ausgeht, wo die UFOs hätten geleakt werden können. Ja. Ich glaube, wenn das so ein Hochauflösungsfoto ist, ich könnte mir keinen Beweis vorstellen, dass man wirklich sagt, okay, es ist ein UFO. Selbst wenn da so ein tanzendes Alien ist, würde ich sagen, ja, das ist ein Gefangene. Will ich in HD, will ich 4K-Alien. Ja, selbst dann, mein Gott, keine Ahnung, das ist halt heutzutage die Romantik raus. Da kannst du sagen, früher hast du dir so eine Gummipuppe hingelegt und alles in Ausland. Früher hättest du es eher noch geglaubt, weil heutzutage kannst du so viel gut auch im VFX-mäßig nachmalen und so weiter, dass du es gar nicht mehr glaubst. Glaubst du, wir hätten UFOs in einem Zeitfenster zwischen Fotos können gemacht werden, werden erfunden? Na gut, nee, daher sind dann auch viele Bildfehler und so. Fotos sind so zuverlässig und klar, dass man UFOs entweder erkennen kann, bis VFX ist so gut möglich.
In diesem Zeitfenster musst du die Situation der Aliens erkennen,
weil alles davor ist Bildfehler oder keine Fotos möglich.
Oder halt fünf Pixel.
Oder fünf Pixel.
Und alles danach jetzt hat jemand bei Photoshop gemacht.
Ja, das ist schon echt schwierig. Ich habe das Fenster verpasst.
Ja, ich glaube auch heute, wenn du noch mal so ein Bigfoot-Foto hast,
wo der ganz nah an die Kamera kommt und sagt ...
Sagst Joko und Klaas haben das gefaked.
Irgendwie, hä, hat der nicht Fingernagellack drauf oder so? Sieht das nicht komisch aus?
Weiß ich nicht. Vor allem, das ist dann auch so, das ist halt ein grosser Affe.
Da war ich bei den T-Rex noch, hatte ich Nagellack oder so, pinke Nägel.
Das hat dich echt traumatisiert, damals im Natural History Museum, dass der so lange Haare hatte, oder so, pinke Nägel. Hatte wunderschöne Nägel.
Das hat dich echt traumatisiert, ne, damals im Natural History Museum, dass der so lange Haare hatte, wie so ein Musiklehrer.
Ey, dann wache ich immer noch nachts auf und denke daran.
Der hat halt so Hand-, so Armkettenkettchen getragen.
So ganz tolle Wimpern, da bin ich ganz lange, tolle lange Wimpern.
Und die machen immer so klick, klick, klick.
Der hatte halt so eine ganz enge schwarze Halskette halt. Also ganz eng, eng an. Nicht der Joker. Und der hatte halt, was wir uns lange nicht erklären konnten, weil seine Füsse sind eigentlich viel zu klein. Wie konnte er das tragen? Stellt sich heraus, er hat halt so Sandalen getragen. Oh mein, aus Blättern hat er sich so Sandälchen gebaut.
Der hat sich halt wirklich aus so auf so Baum getreten, dass
die so oben rüberklappen und hat er dann so wie Sandalen
getragen. Aber auch nur
und die waren nur verbunden wie so Flip-Flops
zwischen Daumen und
Zeige-Zäh hatte der so
einen so einen Bambus-Stahl. Ja, und
deswegen muss man sich das Geräusch eines
anstürmenden T-Rex ungefähr so vorstellen.
Wie ein Deutscher auf Fuerteventura im Prinzip.
Und es gab jetzt auch eine Stimmbandanalyse, also da haben wir tatsächlich Überreste gefunden.
Und wir haben mal rekonstruiert, wie es klingen würde, wenn so ein T-Rex wirklich in vollem Blutrausch schreit.
Hallo, hallo. Hallo, ihr Lieben. wirklich in vollem Blutrausch schreit? Morgen Urwald, wo da auch immer ich zuhause bin, hier geht's jetzt los, ich lauf schon mal los. Achtung, Achtung, jetzt habe ich einen Schlappen verloren. Hups, ich bin aber auch ungeschickt. Ist mir doch mein Hut runtergefallen. Mein Hütchen ist mir runtergefallen und meine grauen Haare versperren mir mein Gesicht. Hat jemand mein Haargummi gesehen?
Oh, hallo. Ein kleiner, dicker Ankylosaurus.
Oh, eine Keule, die macht mir aber Angst.
Oh, da haue ich ab.
Da haue ich ab, lieber. Ich kann auch gar nicht rennen.
Da mache ich mich aus dem Staub.
Da stecke ich jetzt immerhin.
Da verdufte ich mal lieber.
Ich bin müde, weil ich habe auch die meiste Zeit meines Lebens geschlafen.
Jetzt geht es in die Haier.
Wir missen das Tier.
Und am Ende einfach nur alle Wissenschaftler haben den Raum verlassen und niemand will mit den T-Rex erforschen.
Das ist einfach mysteriös. Wir wissen nicht, wie es ist.
Wir wissen es nicht. Wir wissen es nicht. Aber wir wissen es ist. Wir wissen es nicht, wir wissen es nicht.
Aber wir wissen es genau, wir wissen es nicht, wir wissen es nicht, wie er klang, weiß niemand so genau.
Hallo.
Oh, da kann ich nur empfehlen, die Hörbücher von Adolf Hitler.
Nee, die von Christian Ulmen gelesene Peranalter durch die Galaxis-Reihe, die ist ganz fantastisch gelesen. Daher kam auch gerade die Inspiration für den T-Rex, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, weil das ist ganz toll gelesen und da ganz viele tolle Charaktere tauchen auch auf, die er alle ganz toll charakterisiert und in eine ganz eigene Dimension bringt, die seine Stimme. Grossartig. Ganz toll. Christian Ullmann liest Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Und irgendwann habe ich dann alle Bücher gekauft bei Audible. Und dann habe ich auch welche, habe ich die Katze im Sack gekauft so ein bisschen. Da waren nämlich dann die letzten, war nicht mal gelesen von Christian Ullmann. Sondern von Adolf Hitler. Den habe ich auch ein paar Hörbücher eingelesen, einfach so als Hobby. Ja, ja. Ich habe tatsächlich früher auch Hörbücher eingelesen, weil es gibt so eine Open Source Seite, LibriVox heißt die, wo jeder Hörbücher einlesen kann, der will oft natürlich von Copyright-freien, urheberrechtsbefreiten Werken, so alten Sachen. Und da gibt es dann halt so gerade so die klassischen Gedichte und Rilke und Goethe und so. Und da habe ich auch ein Buch eingelesen, aber tatsächlich nie hingeschickt. Also gibt es nicht öffentlich, aber ich habe es fast komplett eingelesen. Und es war so ein ganz schlechter Science-Fiction-Roman. Ich habe auch ganz oft verlesen. Ich habe mich ganz oft verlesen. Seiten und verblättert. Und vor allem wahnsinnig viele Figuren. Und dann ist das ein Kaffee-Fleck hier, oh sorry, da fange ich nochmal kurz, kann ich nicht zu Ende lesen, diesen Absatz, da ist es einfach wie so ein Rauch-Fleck. Ja und dann immer so, die junge Adrette-Admiralin kam auf die Brücke gestürzt. Hey, wir müssen uns unbedingt darum kümmern, uns gegen die Orgolaner zu beschützen. Schubinthin, kommst du essen? Ja, gleich. Wir müssen uns davor wappnen, den Hyperstrahl an... Nee, jetzt.
Ja, nur noch den einen Satz.
Wir müssen uns dazu wappnen, den Hyperstrahl einzusetzen, sagte er.
So, sagte er. So, sende ich das Mikrofon mal weg jetzt hier.
Nein, Entschuldigung, ja, ich...
Okay, noch fünf Minuten, okay?
Ja.
Und der Orgolaner sagte...
Und ich habe immer versucht, diese Stimmen zu machen, und leider sind Bücher oft so geschrieben, dass erst am Ende steht, sagte der und der.
Ja, flüsterte er.
Ja, genau.
Schnell Leute, wir müssen gehen, flüsterte sie.
Oh, ah scheiße.
Ich denke mir auch, wie oft, ich will ja immer die Outtakes von so Büchern lesen.
Oh, ich würde wahnsinnig gerne, das ist übrigens hier meine Bewerbung, ich würde wahnsinnig gerne mal ein Buch einlesen.
Ja.
Ich würde so gerne mal, ich habe ja eine Sprechausbildung, hört man nicht, aber habe ich und deswegen würde ich mir wünschen, ich würde mir das so wünschen, mal einmal, auch warum fragt man nicht uns Podcaster mal, ob wir mal so eine kleine Rolle in so einer, bei den Simpsons oder so Leute, die mal einmal auftauchen bei einer Folge. Weil es professionelle Synchronsprecher gibt, die das gelernt haben und machen. Doch, unendlich viele. Die ganzen Schauspielstudenten werden alle Synchronsprecher. Warum fragt man uns? Ich würde wahnsinnig gerne mal ein Buch einlesen. Ja, LibriVox, nimm dein Lieblingsbuch, lies es ein, schick es ab und jeder kann es runterladen. Aber da muss ich ja irgendwie so ein uraltes Buch nehmen. Open Source. 75 Jahre, da machst du halt Aristoteles. Aber da wurden ja die ganzen Geilen schon eingelesen. So ein schlechtes Science-Fiction-Buch aus dem Jahre 1939. Ja, halt so ein B-Buch von Aristoteles. Ja klar, die Guten kennt jeder, aber der hat halt auch so ein paar schlüpfrige Liebesromane geschrieben, die halt so ein bisschen arg, naja gut. Soapy, ein bisschen, naja, über die Gürtellinie geschossen sind. Und deswegen, deswegen kannst du es dann eins nehmen, so ein Trash-Roman von Aristoteles, so ein griechischer Trash-Roman, so ein Pompeji-Roman. Die schlechten, die ja unter Aristoteles oder Arti. Arti. Wer ist dieser Arti? Auch ein Quatschkopf. Verrückte Leute gewesen. Aber mach das mal. Du kannst es einfach so einlesen. Okay. Ich habe nämlich, auf verlorenen Posten hieß der, hieß das Buch. Und zwar habe ich mir zu Weihnachten dann ein Buch gewünscht, auf verlorenen Posten. Das ist ein Buch von Slavoj Zizek, einem Philosophen, und ich habe tatsächlich einen Science-Fiction-Roman geschenkt bekommen, der auch auf
verlorenen Posten hieß. Natürlich
nichts mit dem Buch zu tun hat, das ich mir gewünscht habe,
aber dann hatte ich diesen Science-Fiction-Roman und dachte mir,
das Einzige, was ich jetzt damit machen kann, ist, ihn
für LibriVox einzulesen. Wirklich?
Und dann dachte ich mir, ich lese dieses komplette
Buch ein, aber es war
echt, weil eigentlich musst du das Buch lesen und dir die Rollen
so rausstreichen, in verschiedenen Farben oder so, damit du die immer mit denselben Stimmen sprechen kannst. Und dann hat mich das Buch so genervt, dass ich meine eigene Science-Fiction-Geschichte geschrieben habe. Die war dann noch schlechter, da wollte ich die einlesen für LibriVox, hatte aber wieder dasselbe Probleme und dann ist nie was raus geworden. Weder aus dem Einlesen noch aus der Science-Fiction-Geschichte ist hier was geworden. Ah, okay. Du kannst meine Science-Fiction-Geschichte einlesen. Das würde ich gerne machen, ja. Aber du kennst mich, ich bin sehr faul, das heißt, die ist halt so eineinhalb Seiten lang. Die ist sehr kurz und inkonsequent wahrscheinlich. Inzwischen hast du die Namen vergessen, die du etabliert hast, und dann warst du so faul nachzulesen, und dann hören Storylines auf, und dann fandest du den anderen Charakter spannender, und dann wird er zur Hauptfigfigur und dann wird sie durcheinander. Wobei, Stefan, hättest du Lust, die einzulesen? Ja. Dann würde ich sagen, werden wir jetzt die Geschichte von Stefan Tietze eingelesen, geschrieben vom 15-jährigen Florentin Will. Echt, die ist 15 Jahre alt? Ich glaube 15, 16 Jahre. Wie lang ist die? Ich glaube, die ist wirklich nicht lang. Die ist wirklich nicht lang. Okay, dann lese ich sie jetzt vor. Ganz, ganz viel Spaß. Ich weiß selber nicht, wie sie heißt. Jetzt bei der Science-Wichtung-Geschichte eingelesen von dem jungen Nachwuchstalent am Hörbuch und Synchronsprecher Himmel Stefan Tietze. Ganz, ganz viel Spaß. The Lollipop Chronicles, Kapitel 1. Im All hört dich niemand würfeln Die Bewohner der Cuselior Sieben hatten sich daran gewöhnt, mit der ständigen Angst vor einem Angriff der Peska zu leben. Seit der grossen Schlacht von Bagvenisch war ein grosser Teil der neumodianischen Flotte zerstört worden, alle verbleibenden Schiffe wurden zerstreut. Nur der enormen Ausdehnung des Alls war es geschuldet, dass der Biosphäre-Kreuzer noch nicht von Detektordrohnen entdeckt wurde. Auch wenn diese riesige Areale scannen konnten, waren sie in der unendlichen Weite des Alls dennoch verloren. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, gefunden zu werden, zu berechnen, war eine beliebte Aufgabe im Statistikunterricht der zweiten Klasse, wenn man den Ingenieurszweig gewählt hatte. Unter den 3600 Überlebenden, deren Leben nur am Zufallsalgorithmus der Navigationsprogramme ihrer Verfolger hing, hatte sich eine Art Endzeitgelassenheit entwickelt. Sie lebten nun wirklich nach dem alten, safonischen Sprichwort Lebe jeden Tag so, als würdest du morgen von einem Bliter-Acht-Partikel-Defraktor erfasst werden. Da ein ähnliches Szenario mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so unwahrscheinlich war, hatte man wirklich nichts zu verlieren und wollte wenigstens jetzt noch in Harmonie und Frieden leben. Dies war auch darauf zurückzuführen, dass Gouverneur Dewey Lumi den Vorschlägen seiner Berater zum Trotz sich dafür entschieden hatte, auf die Souveränität ihrer Bewohner zu bauen und mit offenen Karten zu spielen, um eine Massenpanik zu verhindern. Es war auch seine Entscheidung, alle 55 Tage einen Pseudohilferuf an das mittlerweile schon zerstörte Kommunikationszentrum der Flotte zu senden. Durch die Kodierung konnten die Peska-Signalstöreinheiten nur den Zielort der Nachricht ermitteln, nicht jedoch den. Gut, habe ich sie jetzt eingelesen? Ja. Ich muss es in der Zukunft machen, weil Florentin sie jetzt gerade nicht da hatte. Ja. Aber ihr hört jetzt meine Meinung dazu. Nein, nein. Nein, das machen wir dann nächste Woche. Separat eingelesen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf diese Kurzgeschichte. Ich freue mich jetzt schon darauf.
Ich auch. Ich hoffe, sie ist nicht zu kurz, dass sie nur ein paar Zeilen lang ist, weil ich, wie gesagt, ich habe sehr kurze, sehr unergiebige Kreativschübe und schreibe zwei Zeilen und habe keine Lust mehr. Ja, das kenne ich. Aber vielleicht ist es auch eine geniale Geschichte. Echte Filmrechte, wie gesagt, sind immer noch bei Lars Paulsen tatsächlich, habe ich damals meine Seele verkauft und alles, was daran hört, und Frank Elstner natürlich, aber ja, falls sich Science-Fiction-Regisseure da draußen finden, könnt ihr gerne verfilmen, auf jeden Fall. Ja? Ja. Doch. Ist das hier so Open Source? Open Source, ja. Creative Commons. Creative Commons, falls ihr Manga-Autorin, Autor seid, falls ihr Animes skritzelt, tut es. Dann kann man an dieser Stelle mal einen Podcast empfehlen, Autoren schreiben die besten Geschichten von Jan, unser lieben Freund Jan Horst ins Leben gerufen unter anderem, wo er er jede Woche, ich glaube jede Woche einen Autoren einlädt, der eine Kurzgeschichte rumfliegen, alle Autoren haben irgendwo Kurzgeschichten rumfliegen, die einliest und das ist ganz toll, ich finde das eine ganz tolle Idee. Finde ich super. Hast du auch schon eine eingelesen? Noch nicht. Okay. Ich bin immer dabei. Ich habe tatsächlich schon zugesagt und habe dann aber jede Geschichte, die ich geschrieben habe, für zu schlecht erachtet, um sie einer Öffentlichkeit zu gönnig zu machen. Und deswegen überlegt, eine neue zu schreiben, extra für den Podcast. Weil ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerne machen würde, aber keine habe, die ich gut genug finde. Ja. Aber du bist also, du bewahrst deine Sachen schon auf, so dass wenn du stirbst die Post mortem dann doch noch den Nobelpreis kriegen und dann. Ja, kommt noch an, wie viel, wie oft man sich Mühe geben will, mein Passwort zu knacken. Ja, also daran liegt so ein bisschen, weil, also ich kann euch ja jetzt mal für die Nachwelt konservieren, ja, könnte man alles herausfinden.
Wenn man nur auf Sir John Williams 1234 kommt.
Wenn man auf Stefan Music 94 kommt.
Ja, stimmt.
Es ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so schwierig, das Passwort, was ich habe, zu knacken.
Es ist wirklich nach wie vor sehr einfach.
Stefan Music!
Es ist nach wie vor sehr einfach.
Und es ist nur die Frage, also daran würde man so ein bisschen erkennen, wie viel ich mir nachmenschlich bedeutet habe. Ja, stimmt schon, ne? Weil wenn die sich ein bisschen Mühe geben, dann kriegen die es raus. Letzte Woche war ja Tag des Passworts und ich habe mir jetzt so einen Passwortmanager engagiert. Was heißt engagiert? Das ist ein Typ, der neben dir steht. Ich habe mir eine App installiert. Das ist der Typ, der das ist Heinrich. Der Passwortmanager. Das ist Passwortmanager. Der hat einen grossen Schlüsselbund. Ja, sehe ich. Und da sind alle Schlüssel dran. Hier, das ist Netflix, das ist PayPal, das ist Erwachsenenseiten. Also das ist alles Erwachsenenseite. Und das da unten auch? Genau, die zweite Seite ist komplett dann, wie gesagt, noch ab 18 Segmentegment, sag ich mal. Aber es hat ein bisschen Überhand genommen und ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin mittlerweile zu sicher. Weil selbst für so komplette Crap-Seiten wie Letterbox oder so, wo du halt anklicken kannst, welche Filme du schon gesehen hast. So, selbst dafür habe ich ein 64-stelliges Passwort mit Sternchen und Backslash und solche Sachen, die du auf manchen Rechnern schwierig überhaupt eintippen kannst. Und dann bin ich am Handy und so muss das immer eintippen. Man denkt, als breche ich hier gerade eine Hochsicherheit. Ich habe auch dieses iCloud-Schlüsselbund, der hat halt Tolles, weil der immer wahnsinnig kompliziert sichere Passwörter vorschlägt und so. Und du die immer mit Fingerabdruck dann quasi einloggen, dich einloggen kannst immer. und immer merkt, ist halt geil bis zu dem Punkt, wo du auf deinem neuen Fernseher dann
plötzlich dich in Netflix einloggen musst, du musst halt 64 Stellen bei dieser weirden
Fernsehverbedienung, die ja immer schlecht sind auch und diese Tastaturen sind auch nie
geil und so und dann gibt es halt oft, Netflix hat mittlerweile das ganz geil gemacht, dann
kannst du dich einfach einloggen über deinen Rechner und dann checkt er das, macht mit
einem Code und so, weil alle anderen Apps musst du dann wirklich zehn Minuten bis das Passwort einzugeben. Und dann die ganze Zeit, die du gespart hast davor.
Es ist so lächerlich, vor allem du denkst dir, was beschütze ich hier gerade mit meinem Passwort, dass ich halt irgendwie, mein Gott, zwei Staffeln Dead to Me gesehen habe, so, das ist jetzt die Daten, die geschützt werden.
Aber was ich auch mal gut fand, ich war bei meinem Freund Silvester gefeiert und da waren wir dann alle bei dem zu Hause irgendwie für ein Wochenende, weil der ein bisschen weiter weg gewohnt hat. Und dann hieß es so, ja, hast du Internet hier? Und dann, ja, ja, ich hole kurz das Passwort. Und dann hat er uns so ein Post-it-Note mit wirklich einem 64-Schein-Daten gegeben. Und dann war auch Silvester, da war schon lange zwölf Uhr. Wirklich? So, vier, drei, nicht so, ganz still, ganz still bei Kurde. W, kleines W, großes W, ist es eine Null oder eine O? Hey, frohes neues Jahr, ruhe mal ganz kurz. Muss man probieren, war mal null. Null und dann, okay, merkt der, ein kleines K, wirklich, ich musste das dreimal eingehen, ich denke mir, Alter, aber das ist auch so ein geiler Move, einfach so, hier ist mein Passwort. Ja, und einfach so, wie so eine halbe Buchseite einfach runtergeschrieben. Das Befriedigendste der Welt war, als zum ersten Mal dieses Möchten Sie das Passwort teilen erschienen ist. Ja. Und dann, oder man kriegt es einfach zugeballert von jemandem, oh mein Gott, bin ich Apple-Fan. Nee, aber vor allem, ich bin ja, ich habe ja immer dasselbe Passwort benutzt, und da dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt brauche ich neue Passwörter. Und dann hast du ja so ja so ein Masterpasswort für deinen Passwortmanager. Wenn das jetzt eins, zwei, drei, fünf, sechs ist, hat irgendwas, was man sich leicht merken kann. Dann zahlst du da dein schlechtes Passwort, so dass du dir denkst, okay, der Hacker muss jetzt nicht nur ganz viel erhacken, sondern man macht es ihm leichter, er hackt nur dieses eine Passwortmanagerprogramm. Du bist nur so sicher, wie du selber bist. Vor allem, ich denke mir, wenn ich ein Hacker wäre, ich würde ja nicht Paypal hacken. Nein, du würdest eine Passwortmanagerseite hacken. Du würdest ein 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, das einfache Passwort dem Hacker. Du würdest Stefan Music 94. Richtig, wenn ich es hinkriege, das zu hacken, dann habe ich hier die Passwörter von ganz vielen Leuten und vor allem von reichen Leuten, die sich sowas leisten können.
Wie ein Passwortmanager?
Ja, die was zu verbergen haben.
Ah, okay.
Die was in der Cloud haben. Also wollen wir jetzt bei Donald J. Trump, wollen wir da jetzt mal versuchen, Donald 32 einzugeben?
McDonald.
Ronald.
Ronald McDonald. Der hat doch bestimmt Donald 2, 3 oder so, hat der doch bestimmt. Aber ich fände es auch so, ich stelle mir so vor, wie es ist, wenn du so jemanden auf der Party triffst, angenommen, du triffst Ethan Hawke auf einer Party und ihr versteht euch gut und du sagst irgendwie so, ey, wollen wir einen Kontakt geben, kannst du mir deine E-Mail-Adresse geben? Und er so, ja klar, ethanhawk at gmx.de. Das ist deine E-Mail-Adresse? Ich hätte ihn die ganze Zeit schon schreiben können. Warum denn nicht eigentlich? Ja klar, das ist ... britney.spears at gmail.com Ja klar, bradpitt at aol.de, kein Problem. Aol.de, auch gut. Naja, aber einfach so, das ist deine E-Mail-Adresse.
Es ist so, das habe ich letztens in dem Podcast.
Ad net cologne.
Anscheinend hat ja Steven Spielberg eine ganz leichte E-Mail-Adresse.
Steven Spielberg.
Ad Gmail.
Steven unterstrich Spielberg vielleicht auch.
Man weiß es nicht mehr.
Ad web.de.
Ja, oder nach Hause telefonieren, Ad gmx.de oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber das finde ich auch gut, wenn man so ganz einfache E-Mail-Adressen hat. Warum denn nicht eigentlich? Ja. Wollen die haben ja auch oft an, also Timothy Chalamet, so heißen ja nicht viele Leute. Ja, stimmt eigentlich. Schreibt doch einfach mal alle an timothy.chalamet at gmail.com, weil ohne Scheiß, der ist ja so alt wie wir, der macht sich ja, bevor er berühmt ist, hat er sich ja wie wir alle eine Gmail-Adresse gemacht. Ja, stimmt schon. Jetzt gibt es niemand auf der Welt, der so fancy Eltern hat, die einen Timothy Chalamet nennen. Ja, aber wie machst du das mit den Axons? Ne, die sind ja weg, der ist ja weg. Der ist ja auch, der war ja New Yorker, ist in New York zur Schule gegangen.
Ja, okay, aber jetzt spammt ihn nicht voll mit dummen Gags.
Nein, sagt ihm, wie cool er ist.
Sagt ihm, hey, call me by your name, mega gut.
Big fan.
Big, big fan, greetings from Germany, cool.
Ja.
Ja, einfach ein paar nette Worte.
Und vielleicht will er beim nächsten Auftritt bei Jimmy Fallon sagen, dass es eine Zeit gab, wo ganz Deutschland ihm geschrieben hat, was für tolle Filme er macht. Und sagt ihm, falls er gerade Zeit hat, kann er der Podcast-mässig mal ein bisschen reinhören. Nee, mach das nicht. Nee, mach das nicht. Schreibt bitte einfach nur, hi, I'm a big fan of coming by your name, what a great movie. Also, I'm excited for Dune. I think it will be awesome. Also Interstellar? Also your tiny, tiny, tiny part Interstellar was awesome. It was too small? Way too small. I thought you should have gotten more screen time, like a subplot where you like try to be or at least that you
are the one playing your elder version yeah like on stilts maybe like with a big t-shirt with a big shirt yeah or like like your shadow is being cast against the wall and spigger because it's a lamp just just say that it is something just throwing it out there just if you want to use it Can I use it if you don't, don't. You don't have to. You don't have to, you can. You don't have to, but if you do, would be cool to just give me a call, just give me a ring, give me a heads up. And yeah, do it. And there's a science fiction story. Schreibt nicht Mails wie Telefonanrufe auf der Mail, okay? Schreib's hast viele Dinge zu tun. Dann wieder. Ja, wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es magst.
Können wir den Ebenen, wo es aus dem...
Okay, dann...
Right, that's about it.
Und ja, good luck with your next thing.
timothy.chalamet at gmail.com Eure Arme. Aber schreibt auch ein paar an Britney-Spears. Einfach um es auszugleichen. Aber nur nette Sachen. Nur nette Sachen. Oder musste er oder auch weiss ich nicht, Andy Richter at gmail.com, mussten die halt irgendwann, wenn die zu berühmt wurden, nee, das ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Aber Timothy ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil er in unserem Alter ist. Das stimmt schon. Der war ja in unserem Alter niemand heiß so, niemand niemand heißt auch Stefan Punktiz. Ja, auch Chloe Grace Moretz, das sind, ja, Chloe Moretz, weiß ich nicht. Aber solche Sachen, Will I Am, wie viele Leute gibt es, die so heißen, schreibt dem, I loved you in Black Eyed Peas. Were you the Peas or the Eyes? I never got that name. Wow, ja. Gibt es eine Science-Fiction? Ich meine, ich habe nicht. Aber wenn Sie das machen, dann einfach, ich weiß nicht. Ach Gott. Ja, aber das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Will-i-m. Wenn wir das alle versuchen, bei Namen, die uns einfallen, bei Leuten in unserem Alter, crazy berühmte Leute in unserem, Cardi B at Gmail, ja gut, die heißt ja nicht B mit Nachnamen. Ja, michaelsera at icloud.com, try it. Das ist nicht wahnsinnig lustig. Vielleicht kommen Leute, ich meine die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendjemand durchkommt. Ja, natürlich. Muss doch da sein. frage mich, oder ist das ein Pattern, wenn man lernt, angenommen, weil worüber reden die auch so Emmy-Partys? Sind ja alle bei den Emmys oder bei den Academy Awards und so, die reden ja alle über was. Ich denke mal, wenn du in diesen Kreis kommst, dann kommt ihr an irgendeinem Punkt, kommen die ganzen Jungschauspieler zusammen und sagen, habt ihr auch alle dieses Problem, dass die andere und Leute ihre Mails erraten.
Dass irgendwelche deutschen Idioten ihre scheiß Science-Fiction-Story unterbringen wollen. Du verstehst, was ich meine? Dass sie alle sagen am Buffet dann so, haben die ein Buffet da, ich kann mir keine Ahnung, wie man das nicht vorstellt. Aber dann bist du da bei den Academy Awards, es war Swayze, Swayze, Swayze, Ronan, die auch, ich weiß nicht, den Vornamen ausspricht, Timothy Sturmey, stehen alle, Stehen dann da Michael, Sarah, stehen alle da und wissen nicht genau, wie man damit umgeht und so, und dann kommen die so zusammen, und dann fangen die an, sie sind zu halten und sagen so, ja, habt ihr auch das Problem? Die haben alle zendaya at gmail.com erraten. Ja eben, die müssen ja aber vor allem, das erste Mal, wenn sie dann dumme Mails bekommen, müssen sie ihre E-Mail-Adresse ändern.
Ja genau. Das heißt, diese Leute, die so viel Ruhm und Talent und Fame haben, haben alle lächerliche E-Mail-Adressen und schämen sich wahrscheinlich so.
Das meine ich jetzt ja. Ja. Weil niemand, also wir sind doch nicht die ersten Podcasts, die auf die Idee kommt, oder die ersten Menschen, die auf die Idee kommen, timothy.challamay at gmail.com zu schreiben.
Timothy, can you give me your E-Mail-Adress?
at jbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbjbj Menschen auf die Idee kommen, timothy.chalamet at gmail.com zu schreiben. Tell me with 17 E's. Long, but it's worth it.
Ja, nobody guessed it.
Nobody guessed it yet.
Yet.
They've come to 14 E's, but not yet 16.
Ja, genau, aber das meine ich, dass du irgendwann in so eine Riege aufkommst, wo du auch vielleicht so einen Flyer in die Hand bekommst, wo drinsteht, Dinge, die du jetzt machen musst. Ja, genau.
E-Mail-Adresse ändern.
Schön, das fängt auch so an.
Schön, dass du deinen Namen als E-Mail-Adresse hast.
Das ist ein sehr vergessen. Ja. Du bist berühmt. Du brauchst jetzt eine neue Adresse. Ja. Dann so einen Tipp, was du nehmen kannst. Ja. Du musst auch nicht mehr für ein Auto Geld bezahlen. Okay. Wie heissen Sie? Ich bin der Flyer. Ach so. Okay. Und wenn ich dir eine E-Mail schreiben würde, dann ... Flyer at gmail.com. Okay, okay. Flyer xx7 at gmail.com. Okay, verstehe. Ja, aber du verstehst, was ich meine. Ich glaube, deswegen, lass mal versuchen, aber lass es auch alle nicht traurig sein. Wenn es nicht klappt. Nee, das schon mal vorne weg. Wenn es von der Fake. Wenn wir es nicht schaffen, Christoph Walz in den Podcast einzuladen,
indem wir Chrissi
Walz. Christoph.walz
at iCloud.com
naja.
Hans.lander at iCloud.com
Ja, es gibt auch nur so viel, neben allem.
Also, lass es mal.
Gmail ist sehr hoch
im Kurs, glaube ich. iCloud auch sehr hoch im Kurs. Ja, aber haben die nicht irgendwie, aber at me, ja, schwierig. At me.com noch, ja, Christoph Walz kann auch at me, dem traue ich so zu, einer der ersten Max auch, der hat at me.com. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja so eine exklusive Ad-Seite, die nur Promis benutzen und die niemand kennt. So, dass du dann halt Chloe Grace Moretz at bitchimfamous.com und alle benutzen bitchimfamous. At the Oscars. At the Oscars oder sowas. At the Oscars. Ja. At the Oscar goes to. At the top. Okay. Ja. Nice. Yes. Schnapp mal. Yes. Yes. Jennifer.lopez at the top. Wow, es wird nicht besser, Leute. Haut rein, bitte, bitte schreibt keine nervigen...
Bitte schreibt keine nervigen Mails, geht den Leuten nicht auf die Nerven, nicht zu lang, zwei, drei Sätze, nett gemeint.
Aber wie gesagt...
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr seine Science-Fiction-Geschichte hören wollt...
Muss nicht sein, aber kann sein.
Macht's gut, Baby, ab!
Haut rein, bis nächste Woche!
Is it a Worst Bird Production?
It's a Worst Bird Production.